rogon oi says podcast some people don't
need to I'm just sweating I'm gonna tell
you down a small towel you want me to be
that tower yeah I'll do it I guess I do
now I'll be the small town tomorrow kiss
you on the lips aw it's got lost in your
eyes look at me won't get strep throat
right now Rogan [ __ ] said what a lot
of guys say is when they write a book it
used to be you had to go through first
of all you write a book your publisher
wants you write a much longer book that
you need to that's a big secret
publishing it's got to be 300 pages or
whatever for whatever reason so now you
sell that book now you go on a book tour
you do one episode of Rogan these people
get their idea from that book across
first of all you don't really have to
read the book usually second of all more
people hear about that book themselves
and in ten years then in ten years well
anybody from sam Harris to Neil deGrasse
Tyson these are public intellectuals
that make their living selling books
they do one episode about dad okay no
daddy's giving one episode and they sell
more books from that three hours than
they do in 10 years I mean I'm talking
about I think with Sam Harris talking
about he's he sells hit bestseller he
goes I I can sell more books in you know
in this three hours than I do and how do
you think on it was created yeah they
were doing all right and then they came
on Rogan and Alpha Brett like yeah yeah
of course
so people but you know we talk a lot
about ro you know yeah he's whatever he
literally has v-bit name of show me show
me show me yeah it's the biggest show on
the planet sure we know you and I got in
Stern it's bigger than yeah Oh Bubba not
leaving close it's bigger than Kim
always bigger than 90 not hold on not
they're not in the same [ __ ] lanes as
far as straight-up eyes earballs
yeah it's not even the same sorry again
I've named a [ __ ] now he's big he's
my boy so I defended but yet this is
just numbers it's now that
humans turn yeah not even close you guys
are and turns on PBS compare data yeah
let's see that stuff
yeah that's not [ __ ] what that what
all those numbers all that we could tell
oh yeah oh yeah here's one for you name
last time so what dude you hear that
Stern interview go ahead yeah
go ahead you New York pieces and I'm a
stern fan only tell no you're not no
you're [ __ ] not no I agree with you
and I can see it oh you we can see it
from our own ticket sales or from our
own social medias when you do serious I
mean you don't get a single father I
mean it's like it's like you set it into
your [ __ ] toilet phone but when you
do these podcasts like I'm sure you know
hopefully the fans like us they're you
know the numbers jump the other and then
it's like the tickets jump so it's like
we it's so obvious like it's not even
though we wouldn't have to give us a
millisecond of we would know right away
if it's between Joe Rogan or The Tonight
Show it's like yeah you just if it's
between the fighter in the Canada
Tonight Show you go on the fight and the
kid if you want to sell tickets I'm not
saying I'm anti Tonight Show but it's
like it's we want to sell tickets yeah I
think it's the industry trying to just
convince people that people are still
watching TV when nobody's watching dude
I do know what he's watching but this is
what they decide beyond but this is what
so like on Jimmy Kimmel or a Jimmy
Fallon or who's the who's a big British
guy James Corden see straight oh yeah oh
all they do all they do is do they do
segments to upload the next mortises no
one's watching that I do segments to
upload so they get the digital Marple
karaoke my show my show my show we just
got numbers and I did something
executives downstairs my show on ABC is
I think the second biggest show right
now it's huge right I'm very happy to do
it it doesn't help me one iota selling
take what if I didn't have this I'd be a
dead yeah yeah yeah and that's why I
only take 80% yeah
yes and I saw it wolf Jana saw it
especially in like 2012-2013 had a
really 2011 2011 he was one of the first
guys to hit it on YouTube that huge
character Mauricio Rodriguez das said it
was he went [ __ ] viral in New York and
now and then at that time I remember
when you and you said this we're at
Caroline's he was headlining Caroline's
and at that time Chris D'Elia wasn't
what he was now because he's now it's
obviously [ __ ] you monkey sack now but
at that time he was on Whitney a sitcom
and the rooms weren't even close to he
didn't sell it half the tickets Jana
sold and Yanis was adding shows because
it was just YouTube now definitely get
Chris and now but don't let snapchat
very quickly go say hi to he go we were
watching Chris last night it's like he's
[ __ ] murdering on stage so you get it
but it's like but and then it's and it's
like yeah he's an amazing stand up but
it's like donees why he's packing the
arenas is because it's like the internet
the internet yeah but but also the
internet went oh my god whatever Chris
does that's a funny bit but then when
you seem like holy [ __ ] dude read it but
then it's like word of mouth and then
Chris goes oh you like that video yeah
host something else then he gets on the
mm of rap video say like I'd watch
[ __ ] shirt watch back I've went back
and watched Krista Leah's Instagram
clips to mmm things or the thing we you
know we you know he's doing when he's
those Laurel Yanni sounds from last year
I watch it a thousand times I've watched
your videos when you know you're driving
through the mountains of Utah with your
kids I've watched a thousand times I
jerked off all your content the way you
move I'm saying I've watched the wall
and so but I'm I'm a fan of you guys
because I don't listen to the podcast
that much because I don't have the time
online during all that [ __ ] but I'm
saying yeah I'm a bug chaser I got to go
to [ __ ] Banco Popular and all that
from my Puerto Rican family
metaphorically
no but it's all good I love the Puerto
horn hand um I'm confused yeah and and
and but my point is that I consume your
guy stuff I'm like I'm a fan I know you
guys don't
watching your social medias you know I'm
not at the live shows her and when I at
times like when I do consume your
podcasts through the clips yeah and I
think that's great that's like what most
what happens in five years ten years
wonder what Korea blew the entire thing
everywhere we did it I'll let you know
how it goes yeah I'll let you know I
feel like I'll live like see up there on
let you know right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue Oh what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]